muito bom dia a todos
é como já se falou é a pm pelo pelo
diretor e pelo coordenador nosso pedaço
de pau santilli acho que eu queria
agradecer o convite sempre um prazer
falar dessas coisas na nossa casa e eu
sou honesta eu sou desta casa
portanto estas este teto tem exatamente
ver com momento eu escolhi um momento de
descoberta e podemos mesmo dizer que o
momento da descoberta pelo menos no caso
da investigação científica imagem é um
quê de 10mg portanto eu vou falar de
duas coisas relacionadas que a partir
até parecem que não estão relacionadas
entre si mas que acabam com os táxis são
bactérias e trânsito e como é momentos
gostaria também dizer que o meu primeiro
momento tempo foi em 2008 e tive a honra
de ser convidada pelo manuel forjaz já
não está entre nós eo convidou para ir
ao porto exatamente para falar do
transístor de papel que foi exatamente
nesse ano que surgiu é ver e ouvir que o
gume todo acerca desta desta descoberta
manifestaram na gem por ser um sente um
grande empreendedor social era também um
apaixonado e também conseguiu trazer e e
divulgar em portugal portanto é este
tipo de conferência existentes pronto
vamos falar um pendente sobre é bater e
se o qq bateria shopping informa que
bater em baterias podem estar
relacionadas com eletrônica do papel
ok o que nós chamamos pepe electronics
primeiros feridos explicado porque quer
apenas que não sabem nós e já leram mas
podem não estar ainda muito por dentro
também não vou dar uma aula muito
exaustiva do que se entende por pelo
eletrônico que isto eletrônico porque
nós não é eletrônico e usamos tudo menos
papel constantes loss
esse tipo de coisa geralmente não é
utilizado
e é muito simples
no total o importante é a possibilidade
que nós temos de utilizar suas lojas
neste caso dos ligeiros tal também isso
lógico que vem que a retirada das áreas
e nós dissemos exatamente esse material
como material que é utilizado pode ser
utilizado em termos de eletrônica ou
seja nós conseguimos provar que é
própria celulose como nós a conhecemos
como aterro como aquela que temos numa
folha de papel pode ser usada e pode ser
considrada a qualquer lugar se quiserem
como o material eletrônico e por que nós
mesmos criamos o papel e nós queremos um
outro tipo de material exatamente porque
o papel tem características que são
muito hoje ou seja tem vantagens muito
aliciantes para ser usado não em
fotocópia ou em livros mas em outras
coisas por ter um material muito
abundante importante sendo muito
abundante o seu custo é barato
a tecnologia existe tanto aos chineses
nos mostraram há muitos anos como é que
é possível fazer o papel que tem a
tecnologia está bem está lúcida nós não
precisamos de inovar muito em termos de
tecnologia ou a forma como fazemos papel
é o material que é flexível e tem eleva
o piso é pequeno não se parte e isso tem
muitas vantagens para aquilo que se
chama agora eletrônica flexível em
muitas áreas nós precisamos de ter
portanto em metrô nica sensores sistemas
eletrônicos que possam ser conformava
uma determinada forma
já a frio o seu custo é baixo e leva
esta é a tecnologia está bem está lúcida
só para terem uma ideia se formos lhe
suba à fábrica da portucel em entrar na
linha de produção em vírus como como é
que faço papel portanto a folha de papel
é feita a uma velocidade de 100
quilômetros por hora portanto esta é a
tecnologia atual ferramenta portugal
nessa área é testá lá muito bem e depois
tem uma outra particularidade que nós
nos interessa muito é um material que
não é condutor bastante o material que
nós temos dizer
na promater yao delete com o
materialismo antes nós não temos carros
eléctricos pitso los e depois pode ser
reciclado portanto todas estas vantagens
fizeram é que nós pensávamos que
podíamos utilizar este material que é
tão comum que está em todo o lado em
qualquer parte do mundo e poder lucro
seria poder ser utilizado numa aplicação
para a qual não foi feito hoje em dia
também temos um outro problema em termos
mundiais que aquilo que se ama ou aet
trás
portanto nós produzimos muito eletrônica
muitos computadores de uma série de
equipamento eletrônico e parte a grande
maioria desse equipamento eletrônico não
é reciclado e isso está a causar sérios
problemas em termos em termos mundiais
por exemplo agora vamos ter este
problema portanto não é só computadores
mais importantes do luxor dispositivos
móveis é em nós não estamos a resolver
este problema simplesmente estes
problemas estão a ser deslocalizados ano
nomeadamente do hemisfério norte para
zonas do hemisfério sul nomeadamente a
áfrica e índia china e não é um problema
que se resolve é evidente que ninguém
está a dizer agora é que com eletrônica
do papel este problema se vai funcionar
desde uma alternativa portanto é uma
alternativa é muitas aplicações que hoje
utilizam eletrônica convencional e nós
em 2008 provámos que conseguimos fazer o
primeiro transístor de papel e andarmos
1pd encontra correta com a implementar
aquilo que era a tendência atual
portanto estávamos ainda estamos a ver
uma mensagem de tudo o que sejam livros
jornais etc para dispositivos
eletrônicos também temos os ebooks temos
12 pipas tudo isso tudo isso entre a
substituição de celulose do papel
principal e equipamentos de eletrônica e
de yue qualquer coisa 12 pipas e nós
como que utilizamos nem mesmo um papel
aço lost era um componente eletrônico é
que o que fizemos foi simplesmente
passar o eda esquerda pra direita temos
preferido
enquanto continuamos a ter um pai para
mim mas neste caso mesmo pai perfeito de
abastecê-los o que é que isto não
transitar feitos de papel
neste caso o papel funciona como um
suporte físico porque o trânsito não é
só papel que o movimento tanto são todas
as folhas de papel eram eletrônica mas
neste caso o papel funciona como um
suporte físico para os outros materiais
que contêm constituiu transita por um
som mais dois que são condutores e
semicondutores
é como se fizesse uma fotocópia frente e
verso e tem uma função ativa 35 nós
usamos o papel para escrever ao
photoshop ata de papel serve como
suporte físico da quinta da grafita
neste caso ser como suporte físico mexe
e simultaneamente é um componente ativo
nós começamos a fazer o dispositivo do
mai para as contas e isso a estrutura do
transístor de papel temos uma folha de
papel tem chama secção transversal da
transita temos essa é foi atropela numa
das fácil colocamos um material condutor
na outra faça um material semicondutor é
exatamente como se fizéssemos uma
fotocópia frente e verso e funcionou
isto é são as curvas características
basicamente esse trânsito são suítes são
o nosso futebol está no estado off é
compreender muito pequenina portanto uma
corrente muito baixa no estado ora
recorrente é muito grande e instâncias
separarem estando este grafitar em
escala similar implica portanto
envelheçam são ordens de grandeza
portanto basicamente estão trânsito é
feito em campo e é um sutiã o
interruptor está desligado quando está
ligado
este é o aspecto de transição importante
uma folha de papel ela também temos
papel condutor etc
este é o aspecto importante evoluímos
desde 2008 que se fez o primeiro ep essa
lei e que outras estão a estudar
eletrônica mas depois portanto com com
projetos que incentivemos contratos com
empresas neste momento estamos a fazer
uma série lie eletrônica com em papel
bom agora a segunda parte porque as
bactérias têm a ver com essas coisas
todas as peças são que a gente estranha
as baterias
eletrônica do papel então vamos ver
já há alguns anos um famoso cientista é
pastor descobriu e viu pela primeira vez
identificou as bactérias no vinagre
eu também nessa essa altura descobriu
que um vinagre portanto não somente nós
em nossa casa se não usarmos o vinagre
durante algum tempo vão parar que há uma
lei assim alma públicos em mix forma na
superfície do vinagre entre o vinagre o
equilíbrio a separarem ao situar em
xapuri cozinha vão ver que esse lula é
bom eu não entendo ficou que era
celulose mas identificou que cometeriam
algumas bactérias no vinagre que tenha
uma determinada função e exatamente por
isso elas até foram designadas de
bactéria um acinte exatamente do ácido
acético do binário e só mais tarde em
1886 é que foi possível identificar que
aquela público lula que as bactérias
creditavam erem sul nós
bom isso nós olharmos ser tratados
nessas baterias e se formos ver a um
microscópio eletrônico do regimento
prevê que foi foi investir aqui na na
caparica no cene mata vão ver que temos
baterias que chama escala elas têm
alguns micrômetros são dispositivos
continuamente grandes e que o que
acontece é que elas vão escrita dando
através da membrana filmes fibras de sua
voz
só que grande diferença deste celulósico
imitasse negócio que nós temos no papel
que é de origem vegetal esta é de origem
bacteriana é que estas fibras chão
nanofibras porque tem exatamente a
espessura a dimensão do poro de onde é
captada através da membrana da surda da
bactéria
as propriedades consoantes portanto e
geralmente a natureza é perfeita e nós
tentámos sempre que possível se imitar
não só seguir nos conseguem e 13 nos
ajudar
geralmente os resultados são bons é
celulose é muito cristalina é muito pura
e tem grande vantagem de coletivamente a
abstenção
para além de que eu não sinto de abater
árvores
não preciso de prato mais ou menos cinco
anos não é que o cleiton pinheiro
exa e para fazer estas políticas estas
membranas 200 espécies cinco dias
exatamente se deram nos um alimento
específico e este tipo de bactérias é
mais em pormenor a instituição é um
aspecto das fibras são vez em enormes
portanto coisas muito pequeninas e em
termos de secção transversal 234 mil
folhas portanto as bactérias vão
despertando aquelas públicos e vão
construindo portanto isto serve também
como proteção às próprias bactérias
fazem isto para se protegerem e ficamos
como a censura extremamente de nada bom
a grande vantagem é que estes sendo loss
também chamada né nosso los porque é
feita de nanofibras e transparente para
nós como já trabalhávamos algum tempo
com electrónica transparente juntarmos
estes dois mundos quase opostos
eletrônico é transparente com eletrônica
do papel trabalhando com que lecciona no
país exatamente como as fibras são muito
pequeninas numa interação da luz como a
com o papel normal cujas fibras têm
dimensões e tem em termos de cumprimento
milimétricas e isto é o aspecto de uma
membrana de um papel feito pelas
bactérias dominados
se quiserem importante é transparente
que é uma folha celulose exatamente
começo los do papel a que mais uma vez
fizemos também um transístor desfecho
foi feito um ano passado e o
comportamento exatamente igual ou até
superior
aquilo que nós observamos com o papel
normal tem em termos de origem na
celulose do digital
exatamente porque é este celulose é mais
cristalina e é mais pura franca - do
site isso pois vai se refletir nas
propriedades elétricas dos trânsitos
isto é o aspecto deus isto é uma estuda
uma processo importante do dispositivo
onde se pode ter é essa logo depois os
vários componentes do dow transita dos
serviços também conseguimos fazer
células o assunto que nós trabalhamos
bastante duras e conseguimos produzir
neste substrato uma célula solar
fotovoltaica com recorde
o ideal em termos de células em papel
com uma eficiência de 57 evidente
deficiência muito grande nós pensamento
das aplicações que temos temos muito sol
que não tentar utilizar o sol o sol que
temos e isto foi também muito noticiado
por para além do transistor e desceu a
soar nós queremos utilizar o papel para
várias áreas portanto queremos construir
sistemas que sejam de alguma forma
autossustentável mas cujo componente
principal seja exatamente o papel e
temos memórias baterias mostradores
sensores e biossensores elas usam os
quais conseguimos construir toda esta
medida de dispositivos da eletrônica com
base no papel
isto é equipa e muito importante
há um provérbio efe se quiser ficar
atento vai sozinho se quiser chegar
longe vai acompanhar até agora anunciou
entretanto que vai falar essas coisas e
isto é todo um trabalho de equipa porque
nós temos aqui falar e neste caso eu tô
aqui falar mas está toda uma equipa que
está atrás há muitos anos de trabalho
estão aqui por trás e se não existir um
time warner inc essas coisas
não há sucesso estamos agora no
campeonato europeu de futebol não
começamos muito bem mas a instituição e
quase como futebol é uma coisa bastante
os nerds ontem diferente dos orçamentos
mexe temos que ter é bons jogadores
temos que ter bons treinadores
por acaso até pelos suplentes jogador e
também temos vamos perder peso
miami nos próximos jogos é evidente que
no futebol também há muitos em áudio na
investigação não há tanto era muito
menos mesmo o dinheiro que nós
conseguimos é exatamente convertido
novamente nos laboratórios da equipa de
investigação e para tentar esquecer que
portugal consiga fazer alguma coisa que
tenha visibilidade e queria também para
a companhia para terminar vou lembrar
esta frase do victor hugo 10 na
assembléia pedro henriques difícil e nós
acreditamos muito misto alguns dos
projectos que nos sustentam em termos de
equipa e de infraestrutura e por fim que
estava dispensado este vídeo de dois
minutos que há duas semanas portanto nós
fomos eu eo professor e fomos nomeados
pelo european patent office pelo
instituto europeu de patentes na
categoria de investigação e eu fizer um
vídeo que está a pensar que seria
cliente e tamba acabava que minha
intervenção el cantor universidade nova
de lisboa em portugal e exl e create
feature interno de pet ii e off-line
joni mitchell vi eletronics convencional
electrónicos o iar face meio de prova
numa sessão e até disse eletrônico ice
and export disparou a toada part of the
forest of the way you were here right of
war pigs
o evento existe ou é de o globo
tecnologies em dança infantil photoshop
pequeno mês quando eu for low cost
eletrônica mich from the left to rights
quase piper keep it team type 1 baiano
electrónico componente forte leva
ecológico no twitter
o estatuto e copiou em bons sites
diferentes
deve ter dessa má é péssima
o curso e dom pedro ii plus convencional
mais processa o pet cônsul e que news
vai performada replication deverá
adaptar complications teve onde agora
imaginem de feature phones ainda maior
15 fashion by left to work em do im é
nosso em do im